You're listening to Radio Lab.
Radio from WNYC.
Now for some reason.
The speaker phone doesn't ever want to go off.
Can you guys call me right back and I won't put it on. Okay. All right.
Sorry about that.
Hey I'm Jenna Barone. I'm Robert Krulwich This is Radiolab. And today.
Today we have a story about something that you might not know that you have but
you definitely do have it here.
Sort of a crazy maybe even scary maybe scary even secret a crazy scary secret.
Hello. Hello.
Power. Hey sign it comes to us from our producers Tracy hunt. Hey there.
And Soren Wheeler. Yeah I'm here. OK. No speakerphone. No. OK.
So this story for us got started with this woman Laura Krieger.
Well I am a freelance Internet marketer. She's from Colorado.
And in the mid 90s something happened to Laura that hadn't happened to anyone in
centuries.
So we'll just want you to take effect in 1996 the day you got your jury summons.
That very first one.
Well that was the day of jury duty I had I had totally forgotten about the jury
summons until the day of and I picked it up and I read the back of the summons
and it's just something about six months in jail if you don't show up.
And so I didn't have a ride to the courthouse and so I called the court and
asked them if I really had to show up since I didn't have a ride and they're
like Yeah yeah you have to show up and I said Well I'll have to hitchhike then.
And if if something happens to me I said to them my blood is on your hands.
I wanted to make them feel guilty about making me show up but that didn't work.
She said I had to show up anyway but whatever the point is Laura did get to
court in Guilford County in Colorado.
And when she got there she walked in took a seat.
I think there was about 40 jurors in the pool of jurors and first they fill up
the box with 12 jurors and then they ask them questions about themselves.
Real quick were you hoping to get booted off.
Oh yeah I was hoping to get booted off of course.
Any any good red blooded American was hoping to get towards the end of jury
selection. I was I was one of the last ones to be selected.
So the next day Laura and the 11 other jurors showed up to hear the case and the
case was for this 19 year old girl and she was charged with possession of
methamphetamine.
What happened was is that she was up in a central city which is a gambling town
and that day she was driving in her van with her boyfriend.
And eventually the two of them drove to this casino.
Her boyfriend jumped out of the van he went to the casino and then she kept
driving and then the police pulled her over.
They just for whatever reason pull her over.
I don't know what she got pulled over for they just pull her over and the police
that she got out and put her purse on the hood of the car and then made a
lunging movement towards it which they said give them probable cause to search
her purse because now they're thinking oh did she have a weapon in her purse.
Like what is she trying to hide.
And so the police opened up her purse and they start kind of rifling through it
at which they found this one ounce of methamphetamine.
And so one of the questions before the jury was is this young woman guilty of
possession of methamphetamine beyond a reasonable doubt.
So at the end of the trial Laura and the other 11 jurors got up and went to the
jury room to deliberate.
And so we talked about a lot of things.
One of the things I remember we talked about was whether or not the police were
lying about you know her lunging towards her purse and things like that.
There is also the fact that she did have this map but it was unclear whether it
was actually hers or not.
Because according to the girl when her boyfriend got out of the van he put
something in her purse.
She said without her knowledge this girl saying the meth might be his.
But it's definitely not hers.
I mean to me that's the whole thing.
It's it's an element no one of the possession charges that they have to
knowingly possess.
So for Laura if she said she didn't know she had it and it could be her
boyfriend then she's not guilty.
It seems to her that it was just like a pretty big hole in the prosecution's
case. I mean to me I just couldn't get beyond that.
And so Laura turned to the other jurors and I said to him I was like Well isn't
that enough reasonable doubt for you to a quitter.
And they were all like No she had it in her purse she knew it was there.
It's almost five o'clock. We need to convict her and go home.
But Laura wouldn't budge. She just couldn't get herself to go along.
And so she held out.
And that night when she went home she just kept turning this case over and over
in her mind.
And she started wondering what the girl was looking at as far as a sentence.
Right. But that's not technically what a jury is supposed to do.
No not like the judge in this case.
And generally the judge had told them you know like I'm the one that gets to
decide the sentence. You don't have to worry about the sentence here.
You just have to find out whether she's guilty or not guilty.
But I was worried about the sentence.
You know you have this when you're a juror you have somebody who's liberty in
your hand. And so Laura sat down on her computer she got online.
And she found this criminal statute.
And to her understanding this girl was looking at two to six years and she's
like that it just feels so out of.
Whack. That doesn't feel right. Also it's a felony charge.
You know you can't arrest that.
So the second day of deliberations you know we just went back and forth where
the police lie. Yes. We think the police are lying is that reasonable doubt.
No it's not reasonable doubt.
After all my arguments about reasonable doubt were exhausted.
That's when Laura turned to the other jurors and tried this completely different
tactic.
She looked at him and she was like Look even if you think she's guilty.
We didn't have to convict her for any reason that we could let her go.
But even if she broke the law we could say we don't agree with the law.
You know we're here we're here to be the conscience of the community.
That's what I told them. You don't have to convict her.
But wait that seems like I can I would imagine some people might be like What
are you talking about of course we do we're supposed to just say whether she
broke the law or not. That's what a jury does.
Right. Right. Well that's where everything broke down.
Because as it turns out when Laura started making this argument a whole series
of events set into motion one of the jurors apparently they wrote a note saying
Laura's in here she's talking about sentences.
She's saying that she's only going to acquit this girl.
That note got sent to the judge.
And apparently the judge
exploded and called us all back in and declared a mistrial.
And then about a month later the sheriff showed up at my house with a summons
for contempt of court.
Paul Grant represented Colorado juror Laura Craig home.
And suddenly Laura's story caught fire after she refused to convict a young
woman in a drug case last year.
I was the first juror in for 100 years that I was actually punished for their
verdict. Prosecutor really.
Well actually to end her 26 years.
The point is when Laura told those other jurors they could essentially ignore
the law but they could disregard the facts if they disagreed with the law.
She had tiptoed what you're about to see is going to infuriate a lot of you in
to this very bizarre.
A lone juror tosses out the law almost like a loophole a legal loophole of some
kind.
I think it's absolutely appalling that on some sides people see as a trap door
to anarchy and on other sides people see it as like.
One of the foundational bedrocks of what it means to be in a democracy.
It is something called jury nullification jury nullification.
I have to say the first time I heard about jury nullification I googled it and
the first thing that came up was this YouTube video.
There was like a little explainer thing with an animation and I think it was
like the first thing that was said on the front and kind of frozen screen of the
YouTube video was you can get arrested for talking about this really.
And I was like oh OK I'm hitting play on that. OK let's go.
You can get arrested for talking about this.
Yeah well that ends up being sort of true
but also sort of not. Which is what makes it a loophole. Thank you. Yeah.
Just this way.
Anyway as we dug into it we figured you know we're gonna need some help
understanding this thing.
So I was thinking that would start with a little bit just you know kind of what
jury nullification is. Yeah.
So we called up our favorite legal expert right Ellie missile and I am an editor
of Above the Law and the legal editor of More perfect on WNYC more perfect.
What is that. That sounds amazing. What does that. Well you know what.
It's not worth mentioning anyway. No but seriously.
Season to Season Two is coming anyway when we were talking to Ellie the first
thing that we asked him was you know like just give us a pure uncut version of
jury nullification.
OK.
So a pure aspect of jury nullification would be let's say I am the defendant I
am accused of stealing a car I absolutely stole that car everybody saw they had
me dead to rights.
All you have to have me on video my momma said he's thought it over his DNA is
in my DNA is in the car but I stole the car because my kid was sick and I needed
to get to the hospital to take him to the hospital. I had no other option.
And so I smashed the windows of somebody else's car. I hotwired it.
I put my car in the back.
I drove to the House will save to save my save my kid's life.
Now I'm up for child from the you know the guy who has the Audi that I live in
West Chester. The guy who has the alley is like he stole my car. Which is true.
I demand justice. Yeah.
And the jury says yeah no no we're just gonna let the jury would nullify that
clear that clear illegality that clear crime that I committed.
So it's like yes he took the car but the law the way it's written doesn't
account for the fact that in this particular case that's OK with us. Right.
So that's that's kind of the pure version of it and that's kind of the most kind
of happy clappy. That's a very happy version. Yeah. Version of it. Right.
I could've stolen Justin Bieber's car.
I probably couldn't get convicted in a court for that.
Nobody likes him. Nobody likes him. Right.
So they could be saying the law is not nuanced enough.
They could be saying the punishment is off.
They could be saying in this case the supporters victim sort of deserved it or
they could be saying we disagree with this. All right. OK. Wait.
It's something I understand it's like so.
So here we have a situation where Laura says she doesn't agree with a sentence
like does she or any of the other jurors have like a right to do this.
Is there is there like something written in the Constitution that says they can
do that.
No there's nothing in the Constitution that that directly explicitly says yes
you have the right to completely ignore the law and let off whoever you want to
if you feel like it. That's not a constitutional right. OK.
But it's not exactly a crime because Ellie says a jury is told to do what they
think is best if they think their best is nullifying a law that's also not
exactly illegal which just to get back to Laura for a second is why the court
never actually charged her for jury nullification.
Instead they found her guilty for not answering questions directly during the
jury questioning process.
But eventually that conviction was overturned on appeal because in general the
things that are said in a jury room are protected. They're private. Yeah.
So it's not a right. It's not a crime. What it is is a power.
And so I think of it kind of like. A monster like. The X-Men.
3. So.
Wolverines power. Is he can he can he can detach.
Steel adamantium claws from his hands.
That's just a fact of Wolverine's life. He just. He has the ability to do this.
It's his power.
Now.
Is it a right for him to have claws shooting out of his hands.
No absolutely not.
Is it illegal for him to have claws shooting out of his hands. Well not really.
It's illegal for him to use them in certain ways. Right.
So Wolverine comes into your house and scratches you on the face that's assault.
We have a law against US law proscribing assault but Wolverine has the power to
just walk around as he is with these claws in his hands.
It's built into the nature of his being.
Mm hmm. Real quick to the people who care about superhero powers.
We know that Wolverine's powers actually the ability to heal.
But Ellie's point still holds. Wait a second. This is throwing me off a bit.
So the jury like the claws.
So the jury has this claw like power or whatever but they know they're not
allowed to use it.
I mean his simple point is that jury nullification is as fundamental to juries
as having claws is to Wolverine. That's just a fact of their existence.
But they still get in trouble if they use it lauded.
But then how did we end up in this weird place where you can do it.
You don't have the right to do it but you can do it.
But if you do it or even talk about it you might get in trouble.
That's certainly glad I'm super glad you asked that question because it gives me
a chance.
Hey Matt are you back there can you cue some like English John to seventeen
hundreds type music coming right up.
All right now we're in the mood. All right. Explain. Yeah.
So I ended up finding this guy Jeffrey Abramson Professor of Law and Government
at the University of Texas at Austin.
And Jeffrey told me it all has to do with the sort of battle over who has the
power to decide what the law is.
And he says the opening shots of that battle go all the way back to the William
Penn trial and 16 17 which is really the birth of religious liberty.
I guess you can also accuse him sounds of horses on cobblestone streets and to
do that just do it just do the horses.
So much better. Thank you. OK.
So in 60 and 70 London England we've got a guy William Penn William Penn.
Time was a young man.
He was a Quaker and one day he's walking through the streets of London to hold a
prayer meeting in Grace Church meeting Chapel.
He walks up to the chapel door but.
He finds it locked by the authorities.
And the reason the doors were locked was because there was actually this century
old law on the books that made it a crime to essentially to be a Quaker.
But what Penn does say. That.
OK. One for both of you and to hear you gather round gather Romeos.
Penn starts calling everybody together in the street. Boys gather round.
And as more and more people stick together as a large throng like three or four
hundred people show up. Come on come on. And so.
The authorities seize the occasion
to arrest him for a breach of the peace.
Take your hands off of him. And eventually.
And get thrown in jail and he gets a jury trial.
The indictment is as follows that William Penn of London.
Now the government.
McCain was pretty much just charging Penn for being a Quaker.
But the authorities thought they could go underneath the table and just
prosecute him for what was the common law crime of breach of the peace.
Are you guilty as you stand indicted a matter and form as far as I said or not
guilty I plead not guilty and matter and form and the case is pretty open and
shut.
I mean he gathered hundreds of people in the middle of the street according to
law and the evidence he's guilty but his defense is.
Show me what law in England makes it a crime to worship God in my own way
so the jury went off to the jury room.
But the jurors come back several times and say we cannot agree.
What was their hang up. Well I don't know how.
Inside the heads of those people you can get.
But it seems like they just didn't feel like locking him up for that was the
right thing to do. Even though it was technically against the law.
Right.
And so the judge says that the jurors I am telling you that if the evidence
shows that Penn preached to a throng on a public thoroughfare and he clearly did
you have to find him guilty of the crime of breach of the peace and then the
judge locked him up in the jury room without food tobacco or rest facilities for
a quote considerable amount of time.
End quote. And then finally they come back and acquit him.
The judge accepts the acquittal and then orders the jurors to jail for perjury
put the whole jury in jail. Yeah they get locked up.
But there's one guy in the jury he's like This is not cool.
So that guy ends up filing an appeal.
It went to the highest courts in the realm all the way to the king's court and
the chief justice ruled that it henceforth would be illegal to prosecute jurors
for a not guilty verdict.
So this becomes the start of during a vacation.
And what it really was was the birth of this kind of bubble.
This protected space called the jury room that you can't punish anybody for what
they do in the jury room.
So that notion crosses the Atlantic Ocean and becomes a part of the American
tradition of loss that when the colonies are coming up they have trial by jury
and they have juries and smart people are writing things about how the jury is
the place where the people get to decide what happens and we have to protect
that.
You can't punish them for what they do and so you get people like Adams and
Jefferson making grand arguments about the role of the jury.
And actually Jeffrey says one of the things that we get from a jury is freedom
of the press when the seventeen hundreds this newspaper guy in New York that
supposedly libeled the king or the crown and to the jury in that case it was
pretty clear that he did.
But they decide that the law itself is unjust and boom there you go.
From the press.
So this idea is sort of baked into our nation's beginning of trusting ordinary
people to do the work of justice themselves.
I mean ordinary people being white men at the time.
But then in the mid 80s hundreds. That starts to change because of two things.
One more and more laws are being written and they're just more complex and
complicated. And it is harder for people understand.
Number two the legal world is becoming way more professional more people are
getting legal training even judges who before it didn't have to necessarily have
legal training to become a judge. They're getting legal training.
And so and so now judges are seen as the experts in the law.
And then what happens is that you see more and more judges sort of take back the
power to decide what the law is from the jury.
And the United States Supreme Court made clear in a decision in 1895 that juries
had no responsibility for deciding whether to enforce the law.
Question number one or what the law properly interpreted was question number
two.
And from this you get the sort of judge's instructions that are given to the
jury and we still have this sort of instruction today that ladies and gentlemen
of the jury the case is now upon you. It is your job to find the facts.
But it is my job to instruct you on the law.
Now if they didn't it wasn't exactly that jury nullification became illegal and
more like just the court kind of pushed it down made it sort of unspoken thing.
And over the next 100 years or so it does.
I mean certainly there's times when jurors sort of refuse to convict the famous
cases are like during prohibition and some arguments during the Civil Rights
Movement and the Vietnam War.
But really the explicit idea of jury nullification the idea that this is really
a role for the jury stays mostly underground until.
The claws come out. That's after the break.
With me.
This is Albert in state college Pennsylvania.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred P.
Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the
modern world.
More information about Sloan at WW w w dot Sloan dot org.
Our country continues to grapple with the deep cultural divisions exposed by the
2016 elections.
We felt hope there is some palpable change in how people are looking at us.
Well maybe we are looking at people.
WNYC is talking to a broad range of Americans about how we arrived at this
moment in our political culture.
I'm Kai Wright subscribe to the United States of anxiety culture wars from WNYC
Studios wherever you get your podcasts
Jad Robert Radiolab.
So we're talking about jury nullification which is the power of juries to
perhaps ignore the law.
Tracy hunt and Susan Wheeler are reporters and you guys are saying it was
underground for a while. Yeah and then what happened in the 90s happened.
Page. No.
No. There was a perfect storm of two events both here in California.
First you have the Rodney King trial where you have this videotape.
We've all seen the pictures of Los Angeles police officers beating a man they
had just pulled over in this video you see Rodney King he's on the ground and
police are surrounding him and they're kicking him and beating him with batons
repeatedly showing to most reasonable observers that there was severe police
brutality against an unarmed black man for Los Angeles police officers charged
in the initially the trial was supposed to be held in Los Angeles.
But because of concerns about media exposure they got moved to neighboring
Ventura County where the jury is almost all white.
And after a months long trial and weeks of jury deliberations majority in the
Rodney King case has delivered its verdict and again to the California and
acquittal they acquit the officers not one of the four police officers seen on
videotape beating Mr. King a year ago.
He is guilty of using excessive force. They've all been found not guilty.
And of course they are know like what happened in L.A. after that.
Five days of riots and we've seen rocks and bottles and various things go a car
schoolboy then 60 people were killed. He was bleeding unconscious in the street.
You can see a white plume of smoke.
There was about a billion dollars worth of damages.
There are several other plumes just like that in this area.
I must say I'm scared of what we all saw what happened.
And it looks very much to African-Americans in Los Angeles that these white
people in Simi Valley California had voted race rather than evidence to acquit.
I'm 43 years old.
I have witnessed this for 43 years of my life.
The injustice I cannot even convey to you the heart.
So according to Jeffrey that was round one and then just three years later OK.
It's a white white car you get round to believe that this is the police.
Trust me. OJ Simpson ready to go white Ford Bronco.
There you see the police the media the OJ Simpson truck guy with charges laid by
L.A.
police against OJ Simpson in connection with the brutal slaying of his ex-wife
Nicole and 25 year old Ron gold.
There is massive blood and bloody footprints.
One of the bloody gloves massive DNA evidence blood drops leading up to and
inside the house in his bedroom. And yet a predominantly black jury.
We the jury in the above entitled action find the defendant or job Orenthal
James Simpson not guilty of the crime of murder. Acquit.
When you heard the verdict can we can we ask your reaction.
So while many black people thought that a white jury ignored the law in the
Rodney King case was shot.
Now many white people felt that a largely black jury.
I think it's absolutely appalling it gives me no faith in the jury system
whatsoever.
And then the same thing in acquitting OJ is guilty.
Now he's claiming he got out because the jury was mainly black and according to
Jeffrey these two cases together they've sparked a national conversation about
jury nullification.
The day after the OJ Simpson verdict The Wall Street Journal around a first page
story essentially arguing that in inner cities throughout the country black
jurors were remarkably acquittal prone.
In other words according to the article there was a spike in acquittals among
black jurors in cases where the defendant was also black.
And the most likely explanation is a kind of jury revolt.
Now Jeffrey actually argues that this idea of a jury revolt was overstated in
part because he says you can never really know if a jury is actually ignoring
the law.
But sometimes we as prosecutors would persuade a jury beyond a reasonable doubt.
But the jurors would still find him not guilty.
Georgetown law professor Paul Butler who was a prosecutor in D.C.
at the time says that's exactly what was happening.
Did that feel wrong to you. It did.
You know it felt wrong personally because you know like every prosecutor I want
another notch on my belt so yeah ticked me off.
But the reason they were doing this is because they didn't want to send another
young black man to jail which Paul says was mostly what his job was.
If you go to criminal court in D.C.
you would think that white people don't commit crimes.
They're just utterly absent from the criminal court.
And obviously that's not a reflection of the real world.
And over the years day to day locking up black people it takes a psychic toll.
Paul says he started to ask himself did I go to law school or put black people
in prison. And for me the answer became No.
Well now a black law professor is urging black juries to use nullification in
their fight for racial justice.
That led me to not only understand what these African-American jurors were doing
in D.C. but in cases of non-violent crimes to endorse.
If you let a guilty defendant off isn't that the same as really taking the law
into your own hands.
It absolutely is the same as taking the law into your own hands as a political
protest.
Responded.
So yeah I mean that one sort of seems to grow directly out of the racial mix of
things that were going on in both Rodney King and in the OJ case.
But as this was all bubbling up there is a group called the fully informed
jurors association that started actually in this tiny butthole of a town in
Montana with these like super libertarian you could say that because you are
from Montana. Yes Jack I am from Montana. I am allowed to say that.
And they started this group that was that was basically advocating for jury
nullification writing up pamphlets you know sending out things eventually the
internet comes along and attention to during nullification just can't.
There's cleansing jurors in Atlanta in the mid 1990s started acquitting sports
like bookmaker people defendants on a regular basis even though like in the past
those cases it's been seen as slam dunks.
And in the post trial interviews jurors were saying that they saw the reason was
they saw no moral difference between betting on sports and playing like the
Georgia Lottery.
By the time you get medical marijuana initiatives and around 1996 all sudden
it's become much much more difficult for prosecutors to convince juries convict
in marijuana cases.
And so prosecutors are deciding not even to file charges in those cases it comes
up in gun rape cases. During that time.
So you have like this spasm of interest largely because of these two kinds of
race related trials and then suddenly you have it kind of spreading sort of in
all these different places.
GROSS Yeah but you do rose and in fact today what you're seeing is this kind of
raising activism warning would you like a brochure which goes.
Around getting the word out about jury nullification pressure because jurors
worry where would you like a brochure about you do a lot of this is happening at
courthouses all across the United States in Philadelphia in Florida just say
your name and who you are what you let you do.
We actually sent a reporter to Denver to talk to this guy.
Yeah yeah. Sheriff my name is Mark Yano Charlie.
You spell that last name I a N N I C E L L I.
I am an activist for jury nullification three days a week.
Very cold very hot rain or shine Mark would show up at the courthouse and here's
some other people were out here talking about. CARY Right.
And they would just stand near the steps of the court and hand out these
pamphlets that basically say that because you're right as a juror to the not
guilty if it's a bad law designed by bad politicians you know you have the right
to vote your conscience juries is there to represent the conscience of the
community.
You have the right to judge the law.
You could vote not guilty and not tell anybody.
And as you're right it's perfectly legal. And that's how you get rid of bad law.
And these people various sorts of various sorts.
You'll get the kind of guns rights people you get the libertarians out west with
Occupy Denver you get like occupiers like Mark can you make it sound like a
racial justice people who think there are too many brown people in jail.
So jury nullification is a very big tent.
See there's a there's a there's a prosecutor to see who's got the LV tote bag.
Which is really like a brochure about a jury.
But then the thing is here's where we get to the getting in trouble hard guys
like Mark we got arrested here who hand out these pamphlets in front of
courthouses. They sometimes get arrested.
We will distribute the information.
They came though and they got several videos right here for the fully informed
Jury Association and we were handing them out to everybody.
I got arrested for Southern clothes.
So he's looking good 21 years in prison under what grounds.
Jury tampering almost always jury hampering yeah huh.
But no one ever says no once again recantation is they can't go because
obviously it's not.
And so they get usually they get arrested for for jury tampering but then these
cases will go and they'll get appealed and eventually I don't think we've found
a case where this isn't true every single case the price the charges will get
thrown out because it's free speech.
We are now in a First Amendment free speech of war.
Okay. Julian can you hear us. Yeah up here. Okay. This is Julian heckling.
He became a kind of a jury nullification activist hero of sorts when he was
arrested in 2010 at the federal district court here in Manhattan.
Well I made nine appearances at this courthouse and was arrested five times and
he was about 78 years old at this point and he was just handing out flyers.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you have like a desk or like a table set up or you know any man.
I stand up I have a sign that says jury information and I just as I got a bit go
by. I just pass out this one page flyer.
Do people come up to you when they see jury information like are there some do.
Yeah I do more of them run away.
And he just show up at courthouses like all over the place like in New Jersey
and Pennsylvania and like in Philadelphia and and in Florida.
And actually when we talked to him he was in Orlando staying with his friend
Mark and they were heading down to the local courthouse the following Monday to
urge people to nullify laws they don't agree with basically because they see
nullification as a kind of a check on en times when the government or a law goes
in their view too far.
We have many cases like this that have shown it when the slaves when the slaves
were escaping from the south and going up north.
People were running them up into Canada and they were told that they had to
return home after all the slaves were property what they were guilty of was
theft when they didn't return these slaves.
This is probably the most famous example of jury nullification cases where
northern jurors even though they knew someone had harbored a slave and was
therefore guilty they would just refuse to convict.
They didn't do it.
That's how the that's actually the most important during nullification case that
this country probably ever had because they just let the slaves they just set
them up to Canada they were just violating the law. Out.
That's the point of having a jury.
In fact Thomas Jefferson made the statement The only thing that will save this
country is the jury.
The only thing
hey by the way if you need to stop and take a drink of water don't don't
hesitate.
I need to stop and cry a little.
Mm hmm.
Because anyway let's go and you don't mind if I cry while we talk about this.
Just touches me pretty much.
I mean what is it. I don't.
I of course I don't mind if you cry I got some curious what what is it that's
hitting you in that emotional
I'm sorry I think about these cases that I just can't believe what's happened to
this country.
I can't believe how corrupt this country has become.
And you're seeing that corruption in people being locked away put away for
things they shouldn't be put away for for drugs for example.
Do you know that we now are the number one prison state in the world.
We have the highest percentage of prisoners in any country in the world.
That's the United States of America and of course a lot.
But look at the people 40 percent of the people are in there for drug
violations.
Why does the government have any right to tell you what you can do with your
body. It's the same thing for prostitution.
Why should the government be able to tell you whether you can have sex or
whether you can't have sex or why you can smoke a cigarette or why you can't
smoke a cigarette.
Now I understand why the government tells you you can't shoot somebody else.
To me that makes sense.
But if you want to shoot yourself that's your business anyway.
And I'll tell you something.
We're going to the courts even though to pass out this literature and Monday in
Orlando.
That's why I'm down here and I met in contact with the judge and he's been in
contact with me and he's informed me that if I show up I'll be arrested.
What is the case in North and probably have 50 or 100 people hug.
I hope along with me Jillian and you're going to be.
Is that what you're doing at the courthouse.
You're going to be passing out the jury pamphlets.
That's exactly right. And the judge has promised us that we'll be arrested.
He said he he.
I'm asking all my people to come with guns and shoot the cops that come after
us.
You're not serious about that are you. I am serious.
Well I mean not that that would be the thing that you just said you understand
why the government would stop someone first.
I mean that that crosses a line and right issue there comes a time when you've
got to stop it. And I think that time as much as December 5th
it's got to be ended.
You've got to start killing the police and the guards and hopefully the judges
until they learn how to behave well. But that's not justice either.
The point is we've tried now for years.
It doesn't seem to sink into them that it's their job to uphold the law not to
keep throwing people in prison for 70 years I've been doing this.
And this is the first time it ever occurred to me that I would ever have to do
such a thing. But I can't help it.
I have a hard time no reason why you will be arrested and taken away.
And if they're going to try and do it I want them killed.
But you realize symbol I have a hard time believing that you believe that that
deserves killing. Court clerk who has a job.
How do you know to arrest me.
They've been warned that I've sent them the letter.
I've told them anybody that comes within 15 feet of me.
That's an officer of the court or an appointee of the court that they're to be
removed one way or the other.
I've come to the conclusion that it has to be ended.
Well I think that if you're in I should see that it's ended on December 5th
I put up with it anymore.
I think that if you're in a position of considering doing what you've just said
you're considering doing that.
Then my dad isn't gonna do anything.
It's only if they do something. Well OK.
No matter what we have to do it's not gonna happen again.
Julian I'm going to interrupt you there and just say you know I think I think
we're probably best off just ending the conversation and letting our microphone
person go home and letting me anyway letting you heard my opinion.
It's not only my opinion it's my intention.
Yeah. We hear you. We got it. OK. Thank you very much for having me.
OK thank you. OK.
Bye bye.
Holy. Oh my God. I you have the tape sinkers No.
Yes I do. You want to just give me give them. Yeah.
When I talk to them you never said anything.
Well yeah. What happened after that interview or the tail end of that interview.
So after we hung up we felt we had an obligation to call law enforcement down
there because he it sounded very much like he was making a direct threat with a
time and a place.
And so that Monday he and his friend Mark did show up.
Neither of them were armed.
Neither him or mark any of the other people he'd been wanting to show up.
No it was just them. Nobody else showed up.
And the police say that somebody who works at the court and told him that he had
to leave that he was trespassing.
He refused to leave a police officer then also came.
He was shouting things about shooting police officers at one point.
Apparently he attempted to hit the the court worker but he actually didn't.
And he was charged with threatening public workers assault and trespassing.
So what happened then.
So the charge for threatening public workers that was dropped the prosecutors
dropped that charge.
But he is still facing two misdemeanor charges of assault and trespassing.
Mm hmm.
Did it when you're sitting there in that interview did that change in any way
your feelings one way or the other about jury nullification.
Because I kind of feel like it did for me a little bit.
My aunts will be really short.
No Why no.
I think he's just sort of sounds like a angry frustrated person.
He's he's he's angry about people not letting him talk about what he wants to
talk about in front of a courthouse. Mm hmm.
Join us.
I guess not. I mean I did hear when I was talking to him.
I mean partly because I was had been thinking about jury nullification you know
sort of in the most heroic terms is like this chance to stand up against an
unjust law.
And this conversation just made me realize it can also it also that kind of gets
like twisted up with this really deeply anti-government idea.
You know like you talk to these people and you hear arguments that sound like
burn it down. That's the end that's my problem.
That burn it down instinct.
That's I was always sort of at a distance from me and it felt just much much
closer. Yeah that's kind of my hand when I hear that tape.
I think that's the strain and that's the kind of thinking that you bump into a
lot.
That I find one of the most frightening things I find it more frightening than
almost anything.
What was that idea that like we the people should should be should be triumphant
over everything like that. I find that to be a really scary.
I hope so.
I think like Tracy I I've always thought of this as a checks and balance kind of
thing like you have a system we have a legislative branch that passes laws.
And yes the laws are ill conceived or or or circumstances change or you find out
a consequence of the law.
You know people of one race are constantly going to jail and really gross aren't
getting electrocuted or not.
And then you get these you get these ordinary people walking into these poor
decision points and saying you know what. This doesn't work. This isn't.
Doesn't feel right. It's just wrong.
And that's like if you don't have that then the legislators don't get that
little prick in their little bubble.
I totally hear you. I mean I've never advocate for going along with a bad law.
And I think you are you are rife with bad laws right now.
But there's something potentially corrosive about saying to a person you can
just negate the law.
Think about all the times when white juries in the south refused to convict
people of horrible things. You know it's like that.
I mean I had a jury nullification.
That's that's absolutely jury nullification and that's like that is that is the
history of like post reconstructions s you know. Yeah.
But you can make those same arguments on the other side.
Think about what juries did during the civil rights movement.
This is Supreme Court Justice Sonia Sotomayor speaking at NYU in 2016 if it
weren't for jury nullification we would have many civil rights individuals who
would be convicted felons or otherwise for things that today we think are
protected by the First Amendment.
There is a place I think for a jury nullification finding the balance of that
and the role that a judge should or should not play.
Our forefathers did not believe that juries necessarily always got it right but
it was I think what they believe is that the jury getting wrong was better than
the crown getting it wrong.
It goes at some fundamental level to how we want as a people to be governed.
Do we want to be governed by experts. We want to be governed by each other.
What power do we want each of us to have over the other one.
This is what this question really comes down to this is once again elegant style
legal editor at the WNYC show more perfect.
The older I get the more comfortable I become with the idea of.
An unelected.
White man sitting in judicial robes deciding everything as opposed to 12 random
jerk offs from the street. Really.
And I say that knowing full well that that is a horribly elitist and kind of
terrible for that reason solution to the problem.
We have also puts hand it concentrate power in two mostly white hands.
It concentrates power into mostly white and concentrates power into the system.
When we're saying that one of the only benefits of jury nullification is to be a
check on the system. Right.
If you look at it only from the perspective of the defendant then jury
nullification seems like a great way to protest the system right.
But I'm kind of I've I've started to look at things more from the perspective of
the victim. Which victims are getting justice in which victims are not.
And when I start to look at it from that angle what I see is juries nullifying
cases when the victim is of color or when the victim is a woman.
Try try bringing a rape case try bringing a date rape case in this country.
Try it. It's really hard.
And one of the reasons why it's really hard is the jury is the jury sitting
there talking about.
She was asking for or talking about what was she were talking about how why was
she out that lay any damn way right.
That's not that's that's that's a jury doing that to the woman as much as any as
any other part of the system.
So when I think about it from the perspective of the victim and how is how.
What are the avenues of justice for the victims.
If you're a person of color if you're a minority if you're an Other.
I feel like the jury makes it very hard for you as the victim to get justice.
I feel better about the judge not caring if the people that you shot happened to
be white or black. A jury cares a lot about that.
If you can't convict a cop when you know we did it when you saw him do it when
you can't convict the cop who's not.
Well Scott you can't convict that we can't even indict the cop who choked Eric
Garner to death in broad daylight.
That that to me requires a much more drastic rethink of how we do things in this
country.
And to me the the first people to go have to be these g d jurors.
I find that really persuasive. I I don't.
And on ice and maybe that's because I've served on a bunch of juries.
I've been on about six now and I have time and again been amazed at what one
time I was in a murder case.
Some man had been accused of stabbing a woman 22 times and she died on a
staircase and the forewoman and in New York they just picked the person who's
picked first becomes the four the foreperson. She came in.
She sat down and look how many of you noticed the defendant's lawyer was asleep.
A lot of the time every hand went up we'd all seen this show.
Here's here's what I want you to do.
Let's let's go back over everything that we know and essentially retry the case.
And we we we actually we went we went together through every bit of evidence
looking for some some doubt somewhere.
We staged the stabbing we we went back over the distances where the put could
the guy have gotten from here to there in that amount of time.
I live in that neighborhood. I don't think you can maybe you can we we can't.
We basically did the job of the court. All over again ourselves.
And when we were done. OK let's let's vote now.
And when it became clear to the forewoman that we were going to convict because
she was counting the votes. And finally the 12th vote went to convict.
She just shorter than her chair.
So when she got off her chair she actually was smaller than when she was sitting
on a chair. But she asked us all to hold hands.
We just spent five days we've been sequestered in a hotel.
Each of us had policemen guarding us because there was some violence about it.
So we are standing on here where she has a safe hold hands and then she looks up
at the ceiling.
And it's one of those ordinary rooms and she's addresses the the woman who is
killed.
And she says she says we have spent the last few days trying to do something
that is just you know you were there you died at his hands or didn't.
We decided that you did it and we hope and we pray that this is a system that
works and that you are getting justice.
Then she said God bless America
that's amazing.
Even though I think you're you're expressing that kind of faith in democracy
that it's I think is in short supply right now.
Big thanks to producers Soren Wheeler and Tracy hunt.
We should say a couple of things too.
First of all Jeffrey Abramson his book is called We the jury and also Judge Fred
B Rogers of Colorado.
Nancy Marder a law professor at Chicago Kent College of Law.
Valerie Hans professor of law at Cornell Law School.
Holly Hannaford with the National Center for State Courts.
And Robert Lewis in the WNYC newsroom for helping me out with some public
records stuff.
And one more quick note.
Laura credo the woman from the beginning of the story the juror who got punished
she actually passed away earlier this year.
And we just want to say what a pleasure it was to talk to her and how lucky we
feel to have been able to tell her story.